hey youtubers it's Charlie and Marvel is
getting ready to announce the new
director for the Doctor Strange movie
which kind of confirms it's gonna be one
of those mystery phase 3 movies the
director's name is scott derrickson and
he's really known for doing these creepy
horror movies like The Exorcism of Emily
Rose as well as this newer movie called
sinister with Ethan Hawke that doesn't
mean that Ethan Hawke is going to be dr.
strange but I did want to talk about my
top 10 picks for who I think it should
be just an update on ant-man 2 they
haven't found the new director yet but
the front-runner is rawson thurber he's
the guy who directed dodgeball if you're
finding me for the first time I
typically do Marvel and DC videos every
week be sure to subscribe to get
everything feel free to leave me
suggestions for bonus videos too we're
in the middle of the summer so guardians
is next obviously so I'll be doing a lot
of bonus videos for that leading up to
the movie so Doctor Strange before we
talk about actors let's talk a little
bit about what kind of movie this is
going to be because it's not going to be
like Iron Man with magic it's really the
vibe of the comics that's gonna
influence what kind of movie they're
gonna make which is gonna influence the
kind of actors that they go after the
character at his core has the same call
to action that Tony Stark does but where
Iron Man is a story that revolves around
technology in transparency dr. Strange's
this really dark eerie exploration of
the mind and demons lots of demons which
kind of explains why they would pick a
director that's made a lot of movies
about demons this is a real chance of
being Marvel's first big horror movie
and when I say horror I mean like Disney
horror not Eli Roth torture porn like
hostile just imagine what that would
look like that would be a whole
different type of movie so when we talk
about actors we really have to think
about people that can do really dark
horror movies and come out looking like
an Iron Man level hero just look at him
during Marvel's infinity event last year
I don't think he can even remember the
last time he smiled think about actors
who can make that kind of person
appealing so without further ado here
are my top 10 picks for Doctor Strange
number 10 Jon Hamm
I feel like Jon Hamm is being considered
for every major troubled hero of a
certain age he's done with Mad Men and
even though they still have seven more
episodes to air next year they've shot
everything so he's free to do more
movies now without talking about Don
Draper too much I feel like Jon Hamm is
really good at making unlikable
characters seem very appealing Steven
strange for example
is a way bigger than Tony Stark
when he becomes dr. strange he's full-on
Zen which is almost like the absence of
emotion I'm really just picturing him do
that cold Don Draper stare while he
whispers a spell number nine justin
theroux he was rumored for the role a
long time ago and like Jon Hamm he's
played some darker roles he's got a
strong comedy background but even the
funny characters he's played are super
dark or just downright evil he doesn't
quite have the a-list appeal of some of
the other people on my list but he is a
lot more versatile there can be no
Marvel film without a little bit of
humor so just being really depressing
and good-looking isn't gonna be good
enough the only thing I see keeping him
from doing the movie would be a schedule
conflict with his new HBO series the
leftovers that's Damon Lindelof series
and it's getting pretty good critical
reviews so I don't see him leaving that
for a Marvel film but Never Say Never
number 8 Kit Harington one of a couple
Game of Thrones actors on my list he's
only just started to break out with some
big-budget movies but he's got the
appeal Marvel and Disney want for a
movie like this and because he's
relatively new they can get him on the
cheap as opposed to someone like Johnny
Depp who's super super expensive
he has already booked a movie for 2016
so it might create some schedule
conflicts but if he can do other big
movies and Game of Thrones at the same
time there's no reason he couldn't also
do a Marvel movie while he's doing a
future season 2 Game of Thrones just for
reference to the unofficial release date
for Doctor Strange is may 5th 2017 which
means they'd have to start shooting
around early 2015
most big movies like this or Avengers to
shoot either like 2 years or a year and
a half in advance of their release date
that extra time after that is just when
they work on special effects that's how
long it takes to finish movies number 7
Hugh Laurie this is an unlikely choice
but I feel like he would be so good for
the part I just had to put him on my
list currently he's starring as the
villain in Brad Birds Tomorrowland movie
which is also Disney it's scheduled for
release may 22nd 2017 so it creates some
issues I don't really see Disney's
sticking a lead actor in two of their
big films so close to each other but I
can't help but think that a slightly
more British version of dr. house as
sorcerer supreme would be so amazing to
watch number six Keanu Reeves he's
gotten typecast
roles that are either heavy on
psychology or supernatural forces but
that's only because he can play that
flat dark emotion so well I know a lot
of people give him crap for looking like
he doesn't act at all but I think he'd
be able to pull off the Doctor Strange
persona very well it's the Stephen
strange part I think he'd have more
trouble with I feel like he does a lot
better when characters aren't too
intense like during Constantine when
he's just giving Rachel Vice the
business about angels and demons like
it's no big deal like he's totally over
it
number 5 Aidan Gillen my other Game of
Thrones actor I feel like Littlefinger
would make a great doctor strange just
imagine a slightly less evil version of
Baelish he doesn't look like someone who
could open a hundred and fifty million
dollar movie but he has played so many
amazing dark characters so well I feel
like he would be a welcome addition to
the Avengers roster when you really look
at him the darkest character in my mind
is really the Hulk
in contrast Doctor Strange is dark in
more of an waar way and Gillan I feel
like has that edge to him that Mark
Ruffalo does not Ruffalo is just too
adorable which is not a bad problem to
have I feel like the Doctor Strange
character has a real edge to him that
you can't just put any good-looking a
list Hollywood actor in which kind of
informs my next choices number four
Viggo Mortensen
he's got the charisma to lead a big
movie Aragorn style but he's someone
that has a really easy time disappearing
into characters meaning that when we see
him on screen we don't think about Viggo
we're just thinking about the characters
that he's playing that's what I think of
is like a Johnny Depp problem you know
you're always thinking about Johnny Depp
on screen and it really kind of takes
you out of the movie sometimes that's
why I think that Marvel is gonna try and
find an actor like Viggo who can go
really dark and still be charismatic
without bringing a ton of you know
Hollywood actor baggage to the role and
as an added bonus he hasn't booked any
movies beyond 2014
so he's relatively available and cheap
the only issue I see is that he'd have
to sign that same six picture deal that
Marvel makes all of its actors sign and
I don't know if he'd want to commit to
something for the eight plus years it
would take to fulfill that contract even
in Chris Evans has started to gripe
about his contract and he's only about
halfway through it number three Mads
Mikkelsen anyone who watches Hannibal
will understand how amazing Mads is yes
he is a really really
awful guy in that joke but he has this
really subtle way about him that makes
you both terrified and hypnotized by him
at the same time which is exactly what I
think Marvel will want for Doctor
Strange when you look at pictures of the
character like this you can clearly see
how scary he's meant to be despite being
a force for good you could say that Mads
plays something of a food magician on
Hannibal even if he does use a lot of
people meets but who else thinks that a
Marvel hero who scares the crap out of
you would be so much fun to watch number
two Benedict Cumberbatch probably one of
the most in-demand actors in the world
right now
his Sherlock character is a really good
analog for Stephen strange a
hyperkinetic genius with a lot of pathos
he's even starring in an animated movie
called magic coming out July 14 2016 as
much as I could argue why Benedict
Cumberbatch is an actor has all the
roles required for Doctor Strange I feel
like all of this fandom all over the
world will just think magic Sherlock I
don't think that Marvel or Disney would
have any problem with that but who they
cast is really going to depend on the
director too so as long as derrickson
feels like Cumberbatch would fit in one
of his movies I think it'd be perfect
it's really scheduling issues that would
kill this because Cumberbatch is so
popular right now they've already had to
push Sherlock series for about two years
into the future signing up for six
Marvel movies might not be something
he'd want to do but giant asterisk he
did say that he wanted to be part of the
new Star Wars movies as a Jedi and that
didn't quite work out so there is a
precedent for him aligning himself with
these giant franchises and my number one
pick for Doctor Strange Daniel Bruhl
this might not be a guy you've heard of
or seen but he's been a favorite of
critics recently in really big movies
like rush inglorious basterds and Bourne
Ultimatum you really should check him
out in rush he plays exactly the kind of
antihero you would find in a Marvel
movie and he's got the benefit of being
relatively new I think of his career
right now being a lot like Mark
Ruffalo's and that they've done a lot of
big movies but they're not like Robert
Downey jr. big like he's at his peak
right now but these other two guys are
on the rise Bruhl has this crazy
intensity that I think in combination
with his appeal and availability would
make an amazing Doctor Strange but now
it's your turn let me know in the
comments below who do you think should
play Doctor Strange so the prime not
going to give him a post-credits scene
in any of the future
movies for at least a little while but
the character was part of the original
defenders team so they might debut the
character is part of that series they're
doing that on Netflix in a couple years
one of the biggest issues with casting
an actor for a big movie like this is
that it has to be the right actor at the
right time and a lot of these people on
my list booked their time years in
advance that's typically why most big
actors drop out of movies because they
overlap with other big mega movies that
are trying to make the best example of
this in terms of Marvel movies is Emily
Blunt who was originally supposed to be
Black Widow she had to turn it down
because of a schedule conflict and I
think we're all happy with Scarlett
Johansson but if you want to see a
badass Emily Blunt go see edge of
tomorrow this weekend I'm actually going
to be doing a review of it on Thursday
or Friday so in related news I'm still
working on my next Star Wars bonus video
be sure to subscribe to get it you can
also follow me on social I'll have links
for that at the bottom of the
description Facebook Twitter I'm usually
really good about giving updates on the
new videos that I'm posting right now
click here to learn about the top 5
stories I think they should do for the
Doctor Strange movie and click here to
learn about Thanos in guardians of the
galaxy thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives